[Musique]
tabler sur de vue loin des frontières
une sorte de coeur de paysages du test
range est faite d'avancées simple de
temps contre de poussière elle avait sur
des jupes comme et la réalité des
reflets sur ses cheveux noirs sur
l'impôt un mariage d'ébène et d'ivoire
qu'on se regarde on pouvait voir des
filles des toiles de tout un peuple tu
peux me croire
elle était l'histoire cachée par le
voile des traditions séculaires
elle portait sur son visage de carnet
tél elle tint
pour quand tu disais très loin
tous les virages sont parfois il y avait
sur ses épaules d'un parfum de grève la
gentillesse et la noblesse
ça rien et tout l'amour qu'ils ont
à mon existence se cache et peut-être au
coeur de son silence
[Musique]
si on dit
va falloir lâcher prise vous laisser
porter par la musique
petite chose qui m'avait pourtant l'air
de rien aussi aux cartes du destin à ce
qu'ils voulaient fait confiance que
j'étais déçu au micro lentilles messe de
noël sur wii
on remarque plus exigeantes ne sais pas
comme ça
on peut pas partir sans différence des
maisons de disques nous savons
maintenant j'ai confiance que j'avais
donc
jal quitterait j avoue christine oser
quand répété qu'ils ne paient pas
joyeuse qui
vous avez déjà ça
c'est ma foi
c'est ça
c'est super
nous
[Musique]
c'est
qui
[Musique]
c'est
je
[Musique]
non
plus
tours
montceau
depuis
si et
[Musique]
vous
nous avons
coût
hello
il
tout ça
cette fois je vais
contre vous devrez dire
pas moi
oui
si tu te situes fait
si lui
dans son bus
petit
lourd
c'est tout si tu
sous
m
des doutes
il vous
tous
et tout cet été
[Musique]
petit
pour